today on the anime zone a review of kaon
a show following the story of a group of
girls as they form a band and struggle
towards their dream of playing the music
they love
where the [ __ ] is the music
[Music]
klaus what the [ __ ] are you doing here
this is my show um well you see
how did you even get in my house look i
just figured that your show is pretty
popular so i thought i might just uh so
you flew to england go home and stop
sniffing my laundry but
my flight doesn't leave until tomorrow
fine you can stay but you do know that
chaon is a moe show right
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
the my genre is something i've always
had an actual fear for when it comes to
anime there's just something about cute
girls who look about 12 doing cute
things with eyes that cover half their
[ __ ] face that make me want to leg it
a mile before i inevitably hear the
exasperated
sound that is apparently the only
response a group of cute girls can make
to just about every sentence ever ah
have a problem with cute girls not a big
fan of girls giga klaus don't you start
or so help me sorry continue and so we
have k on an anime seemingly sprung
about because kyoto animation apparently
saw how popular that one concert episode
in haruhi was and decided to base a
whole anime around that episode our
story starts off with yui who uh the
main [ __ ] character who a ditzy
air-headed girl who has just started
high school but has no idea what club to
join and after a bit of [ __ ] around
she decides to finally join
the light music club
come on there's more to it than that
really
really let's see if you can do any
better than well she joins thinking she
could just get by playing the castanets
but the energetic ritzu and her comic
foil meal convince her to be their lead
guitarist even though she can't play the
guitar but
she uh she decides she can learn
and uh
[ __ ] i don't know ah this is hard christ
give me the mic
so the three of them are joined by a
quite rich girl who can play the
keyboards and uh they drink tea and
and eat cakes oh yeah
and uh [ __ ] it nothing nothing happens
in this anime so apparently moe is
japanese for faffing about there is no
grand overarching plot no incredible
drama just girls being silly and eating
cake don't get me wrong i don't think
every anime needs to be paradise lost
but everything in this anime is just so
insubstantial the characters don't even
face any real problems oh no the
guitarist doesn't have a guitar let's
spend an entire episode of everyone
working together in a part-time job to
help her earn some money which in the
end is rendered pointless anyway because
rich girl's dad here apparently owns the
[ __ ] music shop and practically buys
her the guitar let's all go to summer
camp to practice then not practice but
then it doesn't matter because i guess
we didn't need to because why should a
band ever have to practice really the
point we're trying to get is that this
story isn't so much a story as it is
just following four girls acting like
well girls and the plot itself really
just serves to throw these characters
into different situations the girls
consist of your usual array of
stereotypes and tropes that can be found
scattered throughout the slice of life
murray genre but hey maybe it's not
about the characters they make up a band
after all so maybe it's all about the
band and their awesome music no luck
there i'm afraid as well this show is
very much marketed as a musical anime
and the opening and ending would have
you believe that this is an anime about
a group of girls forming a band with the
intent of rocking their cute little
hearts out on stage music is very much
not the main focus of this anime even if
there were a few concert performances to
let you get an idea let me just take you
through the average amount of music they
played per episode
that was it truth be told throughout the
course of 13 episodes they managed to
play a combined total of maybe three
songs and two of them are the same damn
song i understand that bands can be
expensive and writing a bunch of
different interesting songs can be hard
but if you're going to make an anime
about a band then maybe just maybe you
should consider playing a few tunes it
wouldn't have even been so bad if the
songs they ended up playing were well
written catchy rock songs but in the end
the soundtrack consisted of the most
generic uninteresting j-pop run-off that
sounds as boring and redundant as the
plot itself instead the band was just
used as a device to bring the various
different personalities together because
all they seem to do every episode is eat
cake and drink tea yes indeed these
young ladies may not be able to play an
interesting note of music to save their
lives but if there's one thing they know
how to do it's eat cake and drink tea in
fact i can say with some certainty that
they spend more time drinking tea than
they do playing music no but their
fondness of confectionaries goes way
beyond obsession because no matter what
problem arises they seem to solve
everything by eating cake and drinking
some [ __ ] tea someone feeling a
little bit depressed [ __ ] tea
tension is high between bad memories and
a fight about to break out [ __ ]
tea the possible end to the human race
as we know due to natural disasters the
end of the mayan calendar and fallout
from nuclear war from world war three
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] tea
[ __ ] i don't care if sharing
tea and cake is important to their
friendship or even their culture there
are other things people can do when they
want to talk and the anime seems self
self-aware of this in one episode
essentially pointing out how they are
always drinking tea you know what kaon
that doesn't make it okay i can point
out my herpes but that doesn't mean the
chick of the dark street corner will
want to [ __ ] me well you could always
try the chicken and dark back alleys hmm
that's not a bad idea i was joking
speaking of jokes where the hell is the
comedy in the series if this anime
wasn't focusing on the plot or the music
like it was advertised then i would
expect to have more of a comedy side to
it but in all honesty while there were
many scenes that were amusing nothing in
the show actually made me laugh out loud
for any given length of time oh i
disagree what about when mio is
crouching in the corner because she's
afraid
oh look there she goes again
oh man and again
t
[ __ ]
he
but my guess there are approximately 10
funny moments per episode of kaon and 8
out of those 10 are reused every damn
episode the jokes are cute and some are
even a little wacky at first but kaon
has no qualms when it comes to beating a
dead horse but i have to give credit
where credit's due and there are a few
things in this show's favor firstly the
anime is gorgeous with a lot of
attention being paid to the instruments
they play all the instruments are
real-life models and these little things
like this as a fellow guitarist help a
show to stand out though it's a bit
disheartening knowing that this dunce
can afford a better guitar than me
plus the animation especially during the
concert scenes are amazing with the
movements perfectly syncing up to the
music being played nowhere is this more
prevalent than in the opening and
closing songs which are hands down the
best part of the show the music is
surprisingly addictive and the art
stylish especially in the closing song
there's so much attention to detail and
after the first episode it really gives
you hope that the anime will be full of
great stuff like this it isn't but it
should be though then again this is
kyoto animation after all who seem to be
the expert when it comes to creating
addictive and gimmicky opening and
endings right lucky star and haruhi
though i have noticed one reason they
seem to be really well done is because
they're always done in a way where the
animation could go with basically any
music and it'll fit case in point
[Music]
but it's not like i can't see where the
appeal comes from in my sense it
definitely achieves this job because
this shows undoubtedly cute yes it's
really cute there were times in the show
where i even felt like going ah
at which point i stopped watching for a
while through my fear if i was exposed
to this show for too long i would
eventually sprout a vagina sadly aside
from some good credit sequences and a
little attention to detail that's all it
is cute there's nothing else to really
enjoy about this anime the music what
little there is lacks any genuine appeal
which is pretty disappointing for an
anime about a band what little comedy
there is is repeated until it's become
dull or even irritating the characters
aren't even anything more than cookie
cutter cliches with little to separate
them from the horde of high school girls
populating slice of life anime overall
chaos certainly wasn't as bad as i
thought it would be but it really is
just nothing but mediocrity that gains
maybe a few more points for higher
production values it has nothing new to
the table and everything in it has been
done before and better elsewhere if you
want to ban anime go watch becca nana if
you want a slice of life the great as
among the dios done better than this and
if you want a comedy heck angel beats
had me laughing ten times harder than
anything in this and that's not even
primarily a comedy make no mistake this
is nothing more than your typical
run-of-the-mill slice of live show that
has the added gimmick of music in it
though if you're looking for something
cute to watch while completely switching
off your brain you'll probably enjoy
this and if you do please slap yourself
for making the show the basis of about
90 percent of anime coming out now you
mindless moe zombie
you know giga this was pretty fun maybe
next time you can swing by the psohb.com
studio
bye studio do you mean that creepy
basement of yours perhaps and by next
time do you mean sexually assault
perhaps
get out
[Music]